before studying abroad uh as you know
it's it's quite a lingy process um it
requires a lot of funds for personally I
I divided that into three questions so
before studying abroad you should ask
yourself these three questions why you
want to study abroad where you want to
study abroad and when you want to study
abroad so for personally for me uh I
wanted to study abroad because I wanted
to learn about the latest Technologies
so as I've said I'm I'm really
interested in noric so I wanted to learn
about the latest Technologies used in
the field be proteomics metabolomics
genomics and
romics and the second reason why I
wanted to study abroad was to G an
international exposure and to learn from
some of the Pioneers uh in the world